nobody has more respect for women than I
do nobody nobody has more ways everybody
and frankly those sewers have been
largely debunked and I really want to
just talk about something slightly
different she mentions this which is all
fiction or fictionalized probably or
possibly started by her and her very
sleazy campaign but I will tell you what
isn't fictionalized or her emails where
she destroyed 33,000 emails criminally
criminally after getting a subpoena from
the United States Congress what happened
to the FBI I don't know we have a great
general four-star general today you read
it in all the papers going to
potentially serve five years in jail for
lying to the FBI one lie she's lied
hundreds of times to the people to
Congress and to the to the FBI he's
going to probably go to jail this is a
four-star general and she gets away with
it and she can run for the presidency of
the United States that's really what you
should be talking about not fiction
where somebody wants Fame or where they
come out of her crooked campaign
Secretary Clinton well every time Donald
has pushed on something which is
obviously uncomfortable like what these
women are saying he immediately goes to
denying responsibility and it's not just
about women he never apologizes or says
he's sorry for anything so we know what
he has said and what he's done to women
but he also went after a disabled
reporter mocked and mimicked him on
national television
he went after mr. and mrs. Kahn the
parents of a young man who died serving
our country a gold star family because
of their religion he went after John
McCain a prisoner of war said he prefers
people who aren't captured he went after
or a federal judge born in Indiana but
who Donald said couldn't be trusted to
try the fraud and racketeering case
against Trump University because his
parents were Mexican so it's not one
thing this is a pattern a pattern of
divisive nough severe II dark and in
many ways dangerous vision of our
country where he incites violence where
he applauds people who are pushing and
pulling and punching at his rallies that
is not who America is and I hope that as
we move in the last weeks of this
campaign more and more people will
understand what's at stake in this
election it really does come down to
what kind of country we are going to
have so sad when she talks about
violence at my rallies and she caused
the violence but on tape during a lot
the other things are false but honestly
I'd love to talk about getting rid of
Isis and I'd love to talk about other
things okay but those other charges as
she knows there are fullness